was steht an warum machst du das mit den
haaren
die sind in der frist hallo leute ich
jetzt wieder eure machen und willkommen
zu einer neuen folge wie schmeckt
natürlich erkennt ihr schon an meinem
outfit und an dem thema worum es heute
geht wir machen den akku aus kim passe
bild das haben sich auch mal wieder nur
paar tausend leute gewünscht ohne wird
seit dieses outfit trage habe ich so
lust die welt zu retten
vielleicht fange ich mit youtube an
guter content für youtube deutschland
das ist meine mission yahoo.com passen
und ich ziehe aber die hand schon aus
denn mit denen es schwer zu kochen das
ist eigentlich dieser nack der natur ist
eine erfindung von kims france doppel wo
mir vorhin das allererste mal
aufgefallen ist ernst aber stabil
in der sechsten folge der ersten staffel
macht ron einen knacks das ist eine
mischung aus takko und nachos und die
verkaufen sich ganz gut und ich glaub
später den folgen wurde er nochmal zum
millionär deswegen aber hat alles wieder
verloren weil es ist hundstorfer will
der lustige sidekick bei dem rezept habe
ich mich wie immer an den bildern
orientiert und da sieht man eindeutig
ein trottel abladen kieler tor viel
subtiler eine braune mischung aus
hackfleisch und bohnen tomaten und salat
und natürlich nacho käse soße
was habe ich die wichtigste zu vergessen
natürlich und auch nazis oder durch die
idee ist natürlich muss man immer seine
produkte ausprobieren
schaut euch diese käse soße an
[Musik]
jetzt wird es kompliziert denn zum einen
im grünen dieses ding hoch und es ist so
weich und wabbelig und zum anderen gibt
es bilder wo dieser akku einfach für
sich stehen kann
das heißt ich versuche einmal das brot
in so eine form zu kriegen und zwar das
wunderschöne sehen sie hier mein versuch
das ding zum stehen zu bringen also ich
hab das jetzt in so eine kastenform
reingepackt und mit dem ding an der
seite verstärkt dass es so jetzt im ofen
hart wird ich glaube nicht dass es
funktioniert aber fragt uns jetzt mal
kurz in den ofen
vielleicht funktioniert sie hat
natürlich muss man ja auch den ofen
vorheizen
daran denkt man natürlich vorher in der
zeit in der unsere täler in den ofen
muss machen wir diese braune fleisch
passte und zwar dort liebe meine küche
immer noch dafür dass ich das machen
kann es ist so geil am besten machen wir
diese bohn hat falsch masse in einem
topf glaube ich der tat muss waren seien
bei euch dann passiert das hackfleisch
ist jetzt im topf punktgleich kommt dann
die bohnen masse dazu
und wenn die scheiße im topf western
gehören das sieht genau so aus wie es
haben wollte mama hat gekocht lecker
das wird jetzt waren und das kommt in
den ofen und dann sind wir eigentlich
auch schon fast fertig die erste version
die wir ausprobieren dass die woran dann
alles so hoch nimmt und es anders zu
weich und mega sache brauchen wir ein
sonderthema ding und machen eine gute
portion hackfleisch grünzeugs drauf was
soll der geiz war als nächstes kommt ein
guter schuss von unserer käse soße
goldman sachs nicht lecker aussieht
leute salat und tomaten
das ist so football guckt euch das an
unis horst lichters gesehen und
natürlich der krönende abschluss nachos
und jetzt sollten wir dass er einfach
hoch heben können
oh mein gott leute glauben man kann
nicht ganz erfassen wie gut also seht
ihr das jetzt stimmen natürlich wieder
der wichtigsten frage wie schmeckt der
nacken passen will bevor er in meiner
hand zerfällt
guten appetit der nabu aus kompost aber
schmeckt mega gut besonders weil es so
simpel ist und ich glaube ein richtig
geiler party snack durchaus ein bisschen
hackfleisch bohnen tomaten links und
sowas zusammen und dann hast du halt
einen snack oder essen allerdings kann
man ihn nur sehr schlecht essen
und mir ist diese zweite version wurde
die labore von selber steht nicht so
ganz gelungen vielleicht habt ihr es ja
das ist von selbst steht und das ist es
richtig cool aussieht
ich glaube bei nordsee haben die so
thiele zahlen die mega cool aussehen hat
mir nicht gepasst habe früher genauso
gerne geschaut wie ich oder schaut es
heute noch dann schreibt man die
kommentare und wenn ihre rezepte aus
filmen serien habe die ich nach kochen
soll dann unten alles rein ein ganz
kleiner fun fact für euch zum schluss
alle zutaten ich heute verwendet habe
waren vegan und glutenfrei also wo sind
meine veganer und meine routine
intolerant und hifi von euch da draußen
und natürlich alle anderen auch und dann
muss ich sagen sie uns das nächste mal
wieder gibt dem video ein daumen nach
oben
wenn ihr keine posse bald auch noch oder
in die gute laune habt da oben schaut
euch geschmeckt playlist an abonniert
main kanal habt uns alle lieb wir lieben
uns bis dann und wann ist da ist jetzt
aus
bild